so i i wake up oh knock on wood if
you're with me congrats thank goodness
right i wake up
thank you thank god for that and i do
what i do every day here in the
the uh the world of having to sit in a
chair like this and know what's going on
in the sports world best i can
i reach for my phone and i i look at
twitter okay
and then i i notice that uh
the name bob costas is trending and you
could knock me over with a feather
then when i find out why bob is trending
that feather could knock me through to
the center of the universe
is that there's somebody on twitter
and it could be bob at real underscore
bob costas
then you read the twitter bio and you
begin to think something could be up
because it says former nbc sports
broadcaster 21 time emmy award winner 11
time olympic host
president and sole member of the bcfc
bob costas fan club doesn't sound like
bob
no bob has a unique sense of humor so
you know you never know
what does it sound like bob sure enough
we find out it's not bob none other than
his his son
keith is on twitter then his not at his
son
keith olbermann's on twitter saying it's
not him many people
who have ultimate respect in this
business saying it is not him
so i wanted to make sure that we're all
buttoned up
and inviting here on the rich eisen show
to discuss this very subject
is none other than the real actual 100
authentic bob costas how are you bob
i'm good rich and it's appropriate that
i would be on with you because you
have chided me now and then good
naturally are you on twitter yet
what would it take what would have to
happen before
you were ever on twitter and late last
night
and then again this morning when i woke
up dozens of texts
some claiming it must be real some
saying
this can't be true and one said
this is the best indication that hell
has frozen over
since the 04 red sox or the 2016 cubs
but i am here to assure you and
everybody else that the fires of hell
are still very much blazing because i am
absolutely not on twitter
they have taken the bogus account down
and i began thinking you know what would
actually what would i have to do
before i ever gained to be on twitter
what like binge watch the real
housewives of orange county
hire rudy giuliani as my personal
attorney
[Laughter]
make a return trip to sochi just for the
nostalgia
of a pink eye episode
star in a sequel to basketball
or or just for you just for you rich
yes bob make a special trip to the nfl
combo
all those things will happen before i'm
ever on twitter
i mean a prequel to basketball would be
pretty epic prequel
i like it yeah you know what i have to
admit that
so zucker brothers asked me to do a
sequel especially without michael's at
my side yes the basketball
it must it must be done
same thing if lance crowther and and
chris rock say
we're going back to the well with pooty
[Laughter]
tanks
[Laughter]
okay so this is the real bob costas we
can confirm that now
yeah twitter needs that
oh my gosh uh i mean of all the things
in the world
uh so did you did you did you
uh your son uh tweeted it out that this
is not you
and then he did actually add some sort
of caveat to make sure that just in case
my dad has
you know had a complete transformation
personality in the last 12 hours
but there is by the way your son's
avatar uh i don't know if you're aware
of this bob
on twitter i am okay his avatar is willy
mcgee which is fantastic yeah
i mean yeah because he had he he grew up
in st louis and
uh when he was a kid and first loving
baseball willie mcgee was a big star
with the cardinals he's beloved
in saint louis so willie mcgee is his
avatar keith doesn't go on twitter very
much but in this case
uh he had to rush to his twitter account
to set the uh the record
but it does appear that he did text you
the screen grab
of the twitter account asking you what
you want for christmas
that's what that looks like he put up on
his page
right there bob which makes no sense
because ordinarily
he would just call me or text me there
you go with that question okay very good
now for is the one tweet that came out
from the fake bob costas
as you that to me indicated
a thousand percent this was not you uh
are you aware of what this person was
tweeting out in your name bob
not really except uh when i saw the
the first screen grab that that keith
sent to me yes
one tip off should be look i'm a
reasonably
humble and self-effacing guy yes but
what i knowingly shortchange myself
seven emmys i think i couldn't even get
the number of emmys right
exactly i said that i said 21 seems a
little
right you gotta pull a scam get your
ducks in a row
that was fantastic no he he tweeted out
anyone seen like
he tweet he tweeted out this person
tweeted out
uh his or the fake the real bob costas
is
nfl power rankings one through five
currently in the nfl
which to me is that actually that
actually shows
that he might have yes maybe it's a she
who knows this person yes
might actually have a twisted sense of
humor
because as you know rich with all due
respect
to my past history with it to all the
people in the nfl i admire
and respect you know that i have no idea
how to rank teams one through five in
2020
in the nfl if my life depended
on naming the coach of every nfl team
and their starting quarterback
i'd begin making out my will and
testimony
oh my gosh unbelievable okay so
and the account's down now and this so
this this sorted episode is now complete
right
yes okay what a dark day it was although
i'll tell you this though bob uh we've
been talking about it here
we think this is the crowning
achievement
of your career we think this is the cap
this is the capstone
of the career this is essentially your
egot okay
you have the emmys 28 of them right to
be accurate
uh you've got the that's the e the g is
we decided to go with the gowdy award
to prove that you're not in just one but
two professional sports halls of fame
okay that's the one that you got okay
the o is olympics
right and t t is twitter impersonation i
mean that's
that's wow that's that's it that's your
egot bob
what do you think that pretty very
clever and that pretty much does
finish it out i ought to think of this
like ted williams homer in his last at
bath
like jordan's final shot for the bulls
in utah to win the title
this is like walk stuff you don't come
back out there's no encore
it's over it's like johnny carson he
never came back that's right
he bit everybody a very heartfelt good
night they all wondered what he'd do
next
right he didn't do anything
and whoever created at real underscore
bob costas is like the bette midler
singing you out
pretty much is what you're saying right
there yeah
pretty much oh by god
looking at it in an entirely different
light see that's what i figured you
should do
bob i appreciate the time it is not you
that was never you it would never be
does that sum it up
pretty much all right bob best of jill
thanks for the call
you take care all right best of susie
thank you happy holidays
to you there's bob costas everybody
that's the real one
i have not left that hard in quite some
time that's great
would he shortchange himself seven
years that was fantastic
that's the first thing i said this seems
like
to tell bob i didn't have the heart to
tell bob that the reason why it was 21
emmys is because that's what it is on
wikipedia
i mean exactly it's like
and how about the internet's version of
official uh
information and it mostly is accurate
you know and you chastised me for
mentioning pinkeye pre-show bob brought
it up i did not chastise you
i said that i'm cause when we went over
what could the g be
and he got you know
oh that's just really by the way
conjunctivitis is spelled with a j
i think not with a g right that just
made me really wish that bob really was
on twitter
after all of that you know he has to
join us no
he you know there are some people in our
industry for whom twitter is not
is beneath them yes and then bob is
definitely
it you know what i mean i mean we got
that many laughs out of bob
in that amount of time just imagine him
on a daily twitter
le i couldn't i have not laughed that
hard that was good
just don't even cut that up just put
that entire appearance on twitter please
by the way at rich eisenhower by the way
that's literally what smitch just texted
very good well done sean mitchell we're
of like mine
oh my gosh look
i do wake up every day and take a look
at it because i need to know what's
going on
sure right the trending i'm just
wondering if i did not have this
job would i be on twitter yeah
he might i don't know i i would hope not
i don't know twitter is not usually a
good place
because even people who do jobs like
this
still just look at it they might not
post right
the 1980 olympic team yesterday somebody
posts because they always do it every so
often
they go imagine if twitter was around
during 1980
and the 80 olympic team goes back we
lived we don't want twitter
it's like sometimes you just don't want
it yeah don can you put up the
the trending page one more time
because no i'm sorry yeah because i just
just put up the trending
page one more time i just wanted to see
who bob is
was trending with or in between or who
was trending above
and who was trending below because
again it's just one of those it just bob
doesn't you don't have time
he almost went i was hoping that he
doesn't say something disrespectful
about the national football because he
did with
all with due respect and he did not
disrespect there it is okay so he's
trending just beneath happy hump because
it's wednesday
right and then just above rumble and
bellator
oh i mean that's fantastic
oh boy hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here